[Music]
[Applause]
what's up everybody Happy New Year and
welcome to a brand new year of Awesome
comics your one-stop shop for everything
town book entertainment I'm your host
Walter Bernays yak and today we are
talking about the best on-screen
spider-man we got three choices and I'm
sure this is a hot debate I've seen
people talk about it I've had debates
about before but not recorded like this
we're gonna fight it out right now but
before I introduce these lovely folks I
want to remind you to like the Facebook
page facebook.com slash awesome comic
show we have exclusive videos going up
on there every single Thursday including
a couple extra ones that go up we have
you last week we had one go up on Sunday
you never know when a facebook
exclusives gonna go up on there so go
ahead and like that Facebook page for us
okay let's introduce our regulars who
are great people let's go you meanie
miney moe let's go ahead the first
Heather ruse what's up ah nothing much
happy new year how's your new you're
going it's it's going fine so far its
2017 better than 2016 for you know I
didn't hate 2016 Daenerys I mean kind of
nice right a lot of people hate on a
year but it's a period of 12 months
maybe you should you know look at
yourself a little bit okay we're gonna
go down I have to weigh what's going on
hey with that just insulted the whole
audience it's cool times illusion anyway
so mhm
it's not even lioness true are you ready
to defend your spider-man I am ready to
defend my spider me alright great and I
am as well so let's just jump right into
this we're gonna go with the guy who
played spider-man in the first big
motion picture first and as Tobey
Maguire and Ayanna you have Tobey yeah
so what do you the og why is he the best
on-screen spider-man well I think he's
the best on-screen Peter Parker okay uh
you really buy into the geeky loner
photographer in high school and I know
out of them he's the oldest one so I
understand now that the other guys kind
of fit age wise but as the first one I
think you really fit Peter Parker um he
was really awkward and just really fit
Peter Parker until you get in the mask
and then needs this mask because he kind
of fits in somewhere and finally finds
like his calling and he has like a
responsibility to the mask so it's
really nice
to see the separation of why he needs to
be spider-man not only because he has
this responsibility but because from a
selfish standpoint he needs to be
spider-man to actually be someone yeah I
think we see that on the third movie in
spider-man 3 we see that he kind of
needs spider-man few because people
start to like him yeah so he kind of
lets that you know get in his head and
he kind of becomes a little cocky mm-hmm
which is kind of one of the reasons why
I don't like that because I don't think
Peter really lets things get to his head
like that but for the McGuire spider-man
I mean that's what happened I write that
for sure
right and I think in the second one as
well we kind of see the importance of
being able to have to well not being
able to of having to give up the idea of
a normal life in order to be spider-man
it's a sacrifice that he has to be a
hero yes he has to be he doesn't really
have the choice but there is almost a
selfish bit to it that he pulls from as
well right yeah so you know with great
power comes great responsibility I was
bad for how long we're about three
months in if you're waiting for that
waiting for that line three minutes in
folks we got to it for you I tried I
tried to wait as long as possible so
good it did have to be held out yeah
have as you could also as spider-man we
get some really really great long action
sequences in all the movies there's some
really really really great action uh it
helps to have a really good stunt double
but CG counterpart not me Tobey Maguire
whoo that's true making that strider man
yes it counts it's I mean when you break
your back and here the stunt double you
did it you've got a dude right yeah
Seabiscuit man yeah I remember the
rumors about Jake Gyllenhaal was gonna
take over for him remember that because
if they look at similar right at the
time I was like Jake Gyllenhaal but now
after seeing like Nightcrawler and
prisoners and all these other movies
come out with I'm like Jake Gyllenhaal
why did we do yeah why didn't we do that
and you're probably would've been better
you're behind you're part I know I'm
late I'm in like 2004 right now but
that's okay um really quick what do you
think of his relationship with Mary Jane
um I will say on a positive side we got
one of the most epic most iconic
on-screen kisses of old oh yeah I got it
okay down you're kissing the first no I
don't actually really like their
chemistry on-screen very much um and
compared to others who are actually
couples in real life it pales in
comparison however that on campus is one
of the most iconic kisses of all time
mm-hmm name a more iconic kiss I'll wait
how about daredevil season one and
always that time to wait I thought
you're saying daredevil like a movie
when he sees the rain bouncing off
garner exactly don't even know what you
get spider-man you know exactly what kid
is spider-man kid no you're right
exactly that's a good point there that
was the one moment of the chemistry that
really worked okay I got eyes he's a
little creepy
ha ha ha with Mary Jane sometimes right
that's as Peter Parker right you know we
can go back to slavery dance and we're
nomads we could go there any time I am
not even gonna try it in there there you
go you can - no
shop on it strap on in France we are
very excited if you could have fell yes
he's got opinions yeah well okay so I've
had this argument with a few family
members like a lot of friends about this
so the general opinion that I've seen
that I've experienced is that people
like Andrew Garfield as spider-man but
they hate his Peter Parker I like both
okay I think that the authenticity in
his performance in both movies even
though the second one I rewatched last
night and I was like this kind of sucks
except for like the Gwen and Peter stuff
and you know a couple other more human
elements of that movie but yeah I just
think that he heeds not like the
stereotypical Peter Parker he's not like
the the nerdy guy I mean he and everyone
customer says he's the he's just like a
skateboard cool kid he kind of is they
add like I'm hitting her because he's
not a geek he's not he's two Jacquizz
right but he is he still like a loner
and he's still like kind of clumsy and
stuff I think that's that's more of a
well-rounded performance that's more of
like what a real person is there's no
there's not a lot of people walking
around there hell my books fellow whoa
and a tall crown did not know me and I
that's not like it I think that's a
stereotype I don't think that exists all
that much in the real world and I think
that McGuire in the first movie kind of
played that pretty well but as those
moves went on they tried to make him
weirder yeah and the difference between
him and spider-man was greater and
greater I into the trope right I think
yeah I think with Maguire when he was
outside the the mask he was the certain
character and then was in the mask like
if there was no connection whatsoever
and yeah I thought that was a weakness
in his performance where Garfield I mean
he is kind of a smartass as Peter Parker
so when he was a jerk he's kind of a
jerk what a great view first gets his
powers yeah like right you're right
embarrasses that bully on purpose I was
like I love that I kind of love that I
mean like because I mean you only can
take so much of that stuff before he's a
kid isn't ending up for people before he
gets laughs yeah exactly a nice easy
hunting down Uncle Ben's killer which is
like a more of a personal video about
like a revenge thing yeah exactly
exactly
so yeah he definitely took some
liberties with the character but he made
it his own and I think that's you know
more than what McGuire did I think that
he tailored it more to his personality
and I think that shows in his
interactions with the other characters
especially with Gwen with Emma Stone who
might be even better than than a
Garfield in these movies she's great
she's amazing I love it yeah Emma Stone
is great just a great actor in general
and her chemistry obviously they were
dating at the time love 1 & 2 or at
least in two so that the chemistry
between them and the interactions and
just their conversations feel so real
and I think that she improves his
performance so much because we see what
he's fighting for and what he's losing
and what he's you know so conflicted
about the entire time is if especially
the second one is if he should be with
her because he made that promise to
Denis Leary who just shows up you know
that's weird watching that second movie
again we just kind of I laughed like out
loud
and when I saw that yesterday because I
don't remember him just like popping it
so like peer like turns around then
Denis Leary just they're like don't face
just looking at beautifully cracked up
every time yeah
but the point they're trying to hammer
home is his responsibility and that
wastes so heavy on him and you see that
I think in in other aspects to live with
Uncle Ben the first one I thought that
relationship was great and the anger
felt very real and at the end of that
movie when he listens to the the
voicemail that I did tear up a little
bit that because that's a very real
emotion I think that people kind of go
through when you lose someone suddenly
like that is that if you have anything
around you that connects you with that
person you try to identify with that and
make sure you don't forget them and
listening to a voicemail at the end and
it was an inspiring sort of speech that
he had was perfect and I loved his
reactions to that yeah also his
interactions with Aunt May of Sally
Field
I thought Sally Field was a good Aunt
May yeah I know her herself especially
in the second movie she kind of trashed
it and was like you can't she said like
you can't stuff 10 pounds of into a
five-pound bag when I think this quote
I'm pretty sure that's what she said
about the second movie but she had some
really good back-and-forth with Andrew
I thought I saw that they yeah they had
some really real moments and Garfield
had had these little ticks and stuff
that he and you could tell you ad-libs
little things here and there that make
his performance just feel like a real
person and I connected with him way more
as Peter and as spider-man that I did
with McGuire although I did like McGuire
I thought he was fine in the first movie
I really liked McGuire in the first
movie but as they want a second know
about me everyone loves the second
inspire me today I've said on the show
before it's just not my stomach up team
you know I think it's okay and that's it
but uh but I think he kind of degraded
as the movies went along and then the
third one we just get this weird
caricature of him going over the top I
think that sort of goes without saying
right right well I seen it third movies
of a lot of it yeah sure I mean I think
in general Maguire just kind of played
more like a caricature of a person
rather than actual relatable human baby
yeah I agree but yeah that's my main
reason is that I feel like he's an
authentic person and he connects to the
Peter Parker that I know in the comics
just enough where I can make that
connection and say yeah that's Peter
Parker it's a different version of Peter
Parker with little tweaks but he feels
like a real person and that's what I
want to connect with more than staying
and absolutely true to hello Peter
Parker yeah no I got they by the spire
now I'm fine I'm super I'm like I'm like
Stefan and Arkell yeah manners um but
yeah that's that's when I connect with
the most so I haven't odd question for
you though did you read a lot of
spider-man comics in the 90s um yes
kind of him cuz I feel like a constant
theme as I've been having this debate
with friends as well is that a lot of my
friends who read a lot of spider-man in
the 90s love
Garfield spider-man I think because he
was in the 90s he was being portrayed as
a guy like in his like mid-20s right
older and even though he was in high
school in this I mean he acts like a guy
in his mid-20s right and he acts like
that Peter Parker so I I do kind of
identify with him it was just an
observation I had over the years of this
debate and in the 90s about Fox kids
cartoon when he was like in that age
group you so he's like in early like
late college so he's like in his early
20s so that's kind of what I relate more
to Peter Parker and span and then the
high school version oh yeah that's
because you'll get the high school
version yeah the high school version
more has been news the new kid on the
block why is he the best Tom Holland is
by far my favorite spider-man um because
I'm not I've said it on the show in the
past I'm not a huge fan of spider-man
but I just really loved Tom Holland in
civil war and for like the first time in
my comic book love and life I'm actually
excited to be a spider-man spider-man
movie like the trailers racy homecoming
the trailer is great I was not excited
to see any of the other spider-man films
I actually just watched the amazing
spider-man for the first time last night
yeah I was surprised by how much I liked
it cuz I had seen the second one and
hated it but yeah first one to confer
poor Emani is a rhino I don't know
what's going oh there's so many
questions
oh yes anyway Tom Holland blacks get
picked ya get back on Tom one of the
things I really liked about his
performance is that he plays both parts
of the character well like I don't mind
McGuire's Peter Parker and I liked
Garfield spider-man but I feel like
Holland played a good Peter Parker and
spider-man both of them um I like that
he also feels like a real high schooler
that makes sense because like I said
McGuire felt like a caricature and
Garfield felt more like a broody
teenager or maybe someone who was in
their late 20s trying to play a teenager
and thinking like well I was very emo
back then and care to skateboard so
let's go with that yeah whereas I feel
like Holland has a good mix of being
immature and awkward yet still
intelligent and driven and one of the
other things I like about him is that he
also still has this innocence about him
oh yeah you know because in high school
you still have that like you feel like
you know everything but you don't
and you still deal in those absolutes
that I feel like Hollands spider-man
still does like if you're not doing this
then you're the bad guy but if you're
doing this then you're the good guy so I
like that he still has that he captures
that feel of innocence still like the
character he's only been doing it for
six months right
he doesn't have the hardened edge that
Ironman does about the whole superhero
business
yeah that's I was gonna say his
conversations with Tony Stark and Civil
War were great and it did show what kind
of his naivete at that point and um yeah
it is innocence I agree totally with
that there's a lot of genuine human
interaction right and he feels like you
like you said he feels like a teenager
right totally feels like a high school
kid and he's definitely the youngest
right a Spider Man yep because I think
Maguire is like 24 uh Garfield was like
28 there's young yes no there's only 24
when he started yeah but don't look
Garfield does look young for his age but
like for a high schooler it's like I
combined was like a college student but
yeah yeah my school kind of kind of
stepping over a little bit didn't
distract too much from the movie for me
but he feels Tom how it feels like a
real teenager cuz I think he's like 19
right now right yeah I believe the
computer told me 20 yesterday okay yeah
yeah but he's still a young guy right
but he looks young too so I think that
helps when you know that aesthetic is
there when you can easily more easily
buy into it than what the McGuire or
Garfield's also in the Spidey suit
especially in like the airport sequence
of civil would finally get to see
spider-man mix and quips yes quips but
not yeah yeah there's a couple of
moments where Garfield does that I feel
does it but and the first ones kind of
angry but then it came yeah right I'm
sorry avoid a playful like annoying I
don't know like there's this edge to
spider-man that makes him annoying
uh-huh - his villains as much as like
anything else
mm-hmm and I think yeah it's I'm Holland
when he finally like one of those quips
you right he's annoying to the heroes
great right because he's almost trying
to the heart as he would like if the
Avengers just shot on your doorstep you
try really hard
I love dude you have a middle arm that's
awesome yeah that was great
right cuz it feels it feels genuine it
feels like something that a real person
in that situation a kid how they would
react to a situation
great stuff which is great acting right
really in writing right yeah I don't
know if you agree to disagree but I
think he by far has the best suit does
that one that I like a classic in it
yeah I might I might agree with you okay
I needed more time
that's my give me more time that I have
your honors I'm all just dudes
yeah then again I have that on old
costumes right brother so I think each
one has its own little things that I
love about them that I hate about them
honestly yeah I'm really excited to see
what they do with like the the wings and
everything bring it back yeah that's
very good
and see in um in Civil War I thought it
was like all CG or something you gotta
correct me if I'm wrong on that but I
know in the in the actual homecoming
it's definitely a suit by and see in
Civil War I was like is that I couldn't
tell if it was like I know CG or not but
anyway it does look cool because I like
the classic look and the thick black
around the eyes and their nd emotive
eyes yeah there probably helps do with
like the app ya know Oh totally moving
really yeah absolutely and I like how
they said Tony Stark built the suit kind
of suit I mean that that's in there that
makes sense right I like answer to ammo
out of just this yeah right right um but
yeah okay we're gonna we're gonna wrap
this up here I really quickly would like
to do a quick comic book pick of the
week and right now I'm reading a Spider
Man dead no more the clone conspiracy
and spoilers for that if you haven't
read yet but Ben Riley has Richard hi
I've been waiting since I started
reading comic books for Ben Reilly to
come back and he's back he's back not in
the role I thought I'd see him in but
I'm willing to give this time to breathe
here he's back I am so excited to see
where they go with it so check out the
clone conspiracy su4 comes out and I
think two weeks from now so go and check
that out it's really interesting they
bring a ton of characters back it was
dead I mean that's that's the whole
point of the the storyline so I think
you guys might enjoy that there's a lot
of old favorites that come back so go
ahead and check out the clone conspiracy
okay we're gonna wrap this up Heather
where can we find you on social media um
you can find me on Twitter at Heather
ruse or Instagram at a truce check her
out on there Ayana twitter facebook
right here uh yes snapchat chap that
snap mate that's something like that you
can find me on twitter at awesome
underscore Walter I think I'm going to
make a Facebook page because I get a lot
and requests from you guys at the max
yeah I'm totally maxed I'm friend
requests so I'm gonna probably make a
Facebook page coming up soon as you guys
could get a hold me on there let you
know the link when that comes up but
right now in facebook we always have our
Facebook page as it mentioned before
facebook.com slash awesome comic show so
go ahead and give that a like Porter put
up he was not here today but he did put
up a video about Batman about it was a
little quiet yeah where to put up a
video by Ben Affleck saying that he's
not gonna do a Batman movie unless the
script is right which is the right call
Ben so get Portus thoughts on that by
going to our Facebook page
alright everybody so until next week we
will return with a brand new episode of
awesome comics so we'll see you then and
we'll see you online expect whip
[Applause]